anthony blinken landes principaux
conseillers de joe biden en matière de
politique étrangère à l'instar du
président élu le francophone et
francophile de 58 ans souhaite que les
états unis retrouvent leur place dans le
concert des nations
le futur chef de la diplomatie
américaine aura du pain sur la planche
après l'abandon successifs par
l'administration trempe d'allianz est
accords internationaux
anthony blinken devrait notamment
empêché la sortie des états unis de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
ressuciter l'accord sur le nucléaire
iranien et rejoindre l'accord de paris
sur le climat à l'accord sur le climat
que john kerry lui-même avait négocié en
décembre 2015 alors chef de la
diplomatie
signe de l'importance que porte joe
biden à ce dossier
john kerry sera l'émissaire spécial du
président élu pour le climat l'ancien
secrétaire d'état de barack obama âgé de
76 ans siégera au conseil de sécurité
nationale de la maison blanche
et c'est bien la première fois qu'un de
ses membres est spécifiquement chargés
des questions climatiques
aux etats unis alejandro mayorkas ce est
né à la havane en 1959 ce fils de
réfugiés anticastriste sera le premier
hispanique a dirigé le ministère de la
sécurité intérieure aux états unis un
département qui supervise notamment les
questions d'immigration
alejandro mayorkas ce ancien procureur
fédéral connaît bien cette
administration dont il fut ministre
adjoint de 2013 à 2016
le président élu a également sélectionné
avril hence pour prendre la tête de la
direction du renseignement national un
poste uniquement occupés par des hommes
jusqu'ici avril à 51 ans en
directrice adjointe de la cia sera la
femme la plus haut placée dans la
communauté du renseignement
enfin l'afro américaine linda thomass
greenfield deviendra de son côté
ambassadrice à l'onu
la diplomate chevronné de 68 ans fut
entre autres secrétaire d'état adjointe
pour l'afrique est ambassadrice au
liberia